je voulais poser une dernière question
si vous le voulez bien parce qu'on a
appris aujourd'hui que le maire de
Saint-Brevin Yannick Morèze a
démissionné après que son domicile a été
incendié le maire qui dénonce dans un
courrier adressé au préfet dans lequel
il démissionne un manque de soutien de
la part de l'État quel est votre
réaction à cette information je pense
que c'est extrêmement grave que un maire
d'une commune en Loire-Atlantique parce
qu'il a été volontaire pour accueillir
je crois un centre d'accueil de migrants
dans sa commune était jusqu'à voir ces
véhicules sa maison incendiée et
aujourd'hui choisissent de démissionner
en dénonçant le manque de soutien de
l'État quand on sait
voilà le l'engagement aujourd'hui du
gouvernement à lutter contre toutes les
contestations qui viennent de la gauche
qu'il soit aujourd'hui aussi passif face
à la menace de l'extrême droite on l'a
vu avec la non interdiction de la
dernière manifestation à Paris et
aujourd'hui la non pro de sommaire ce
qui rentre aussi d'ailleurs dans les
interpellations que nous avons notamment
ici au Sénat sur la protection des élus
et des mers face aux violences c'est
extrêmement grave ça doit déclencher une
prise de conscience et un véritable
changement
[Musique]